if i'm a kilo overweight i can lose up  to two seconds in the race distance  so my weight is very important and also  during the weight i lose up to four  kilos in the race in an hour and 45  minutes yeah but this is because it gets  so hot isn't it that so if you're in  something like singapore or malaysia or  something yeah those ones are killer um  but also because it's just incredibly  physical yeah and uh the g-force that we  pull when you go i mean the things like  on rails so when you're doing 150 180  miles an hour and you turn the thing  turns and your body wants to go the  opposite way so you have to have a  really good core stability you can't be  big and bulky if you have your weight  you know if i was super muscly up here  my weight would be too high so i have to  do lots of squats from the butt okay so  but  i'd like to watch that routine